we could talk to you about your daughter
jane
before she was 11 she was jane ives but
how exactly did she wind up in the
hawkins lab we've been buzzing to see
what stories will unfold in the fourth
season of stranger things
eleven has had such a traumatic life
from being kidnapped from her mother to
all the mistreatment she faced while
stuck at the hawkins lab
we've met her lab sister callie so is it
time to meet the rest of her siblings
how about the truth of who eleven's
birth father is i think this is why mama
wanted to talk
over the first three seasons of stranger
things we've gotten glimpses into the
dark past that eleven has faced and it
seems like season four will offer us
some more insight into her origin story
but why have there been so many secrets
surrounding it up until now
while we know eleven and cali aka eight
managed to escape
there were also other children who were
in the hawkins lab with them that we got
to meet in the comics like three
aka ricky six aka francine
9 aka jaime and 9.5
aka marcy but we still don't know what
happened to all of them
a season 4 teaser potentially gives us
some clues as there are numbers that
appear throughout
we've got the clock set at three a
reflection into the camera of the
rainbow that looks a bit like a five
and the disc in the pachinko like
machine that lands in the seventh slot
now that the series has established
enough of the backstory and eleven is
facing being separated from the
strongest father figure she's ever had
judging by the trailer the show might
just be ready to share more information
about her past and the other children
who were at the hawkins lab
obviously eleven's past has been
extremely traumatic
and we know that until now she's
forgotten many details of her life at
the lab
like the existence of the rainbow room
that cali brought back to her memory
it's taken some time but seeing the
rainbow room once again makes us think
that much more will be revealed and it
might just come from the people that she
grew up with at the hawkins lab
we also have been told by members of the
team that season 4 would be
very dark and we'd experience an intense
ride through hawkins
from what we gather in the flashback to
the lab trailer the image we see of
eleven's face is seemingly
from the present day and could indicate
that this is a dream or potentially a
real memory
what more will we hear from dr brenner
he did say there was something special
for the children to see
yeah i understand
we've slowly discovered bits of eleven's
past throughout the series and
it's all extremely dark dr brenner used
her for her powers and put her in the
position of having to help gaining intel
on a russian agent
yes the bat she also did spend a lot of
time in a sensory deprivation tank which
also led to more terrible things like
the demogorgon she encountered after
opening the gate to the upside down
as if that weren't difficult enough
brenner made her face the demogorgon
again
let's not forget the fact that when she
wasn't being put through grueling
psychological tests
levin was also locked away by herself
with only dr brenner for company on
occasion
she's been through a lot and also has to
deal with the horror and guilt that came
with the lives that she ended
there is definitely trauma that could be
getting in the way of her discovering
the truth
we also know she was punished at the
facility anytime she disobeyed dr
brenner
and seeing her locked away in the
trailer only enforced that horrifying
memory
as for papa aka dr brenner aka
bad man we know eleven is not a fan even
though he presented himself as a father
figure to her
eleven can you hear me
though since he kept her separated from
the others so often it's a hint that she
was special to him
we make history
before there was the eleven we all know
and love she was jane ives
however the fact is jane never really
got the chance to live a normal life
she's the biological daughter of terry
ives but the question of who her actual
father is remains a mystery
since terry was being given psychedelic
drugs and put in isolation tanks by dr
brenner as one of the test subjects of
the mk ultra project
when she suddenly got pregnant he played
a vital part in what levin's existence
was
one full of psychokinetic abilities
terry ives never got to know jane ives
since she was immediately kidnapped by
brenner and
even though she tried to file a lawsuit
the lab was miles ahead of her and
covered up
any evidence of jane ives terry
pretends like jane is real now there was
only 11. since we've met terry before
there's definitely a chance of her
making another appearance
of course we don't know how many answers
she would have since she did suffer so
much brain damage from dr brenner's
electro-convulsive therapy
however terry was able to communicate
with eleven when she guided her through
the lights before
one of the biggest questions we have
left now is who
exactly is eleven's biological father in
the thai and
all of suspicious minds it's revealed
that a man named andrew rich
is the actual father of eleven though he
never knew her since he was supposedly
drafted vietnam before she was born
now the 11 is separated from jim hopper
who we last saw stuck in russia
discovering the answers to mysteries
from her past could help her connect
with her family
both chosen and biological you know the
heart to heart
when joe kiri said season four would be
the darkest season of stranger things
yet
he definitely wasn't kidding the hawkins
lab
obviously played a pivotal role in
levin's life so we'd love to learn more
about that dark history
do you think we'll finally find out who
eleven's biological father is
you